hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master arc I think I should know
who that is but have forgotten akshay
ake hora ok people really torture me
with the with the Italian game oh he
goes further for the evidence sorry
after it's like looking through for Kim
[Music]
so Bishop Bishop f5 is the best move but
I tend to forget it how it works so
let's do it it's it's going to be risky
because I constantly forgot forget the
details
this is how it works but don't ask me
how it continues i made a video on that
but i still have forgotten the details
yeah Knight a5 is the rather obvious
idea so just goes there what is correct
here mmm a six maybe just a six and now
if I go here trading Queens cannot be
bad check okay I thought you would try
to annoy me with the pin somehow but
doesn't look like it so what's going on
here
let's see Forrester idea i'm not quite
sure about it yeah maybe i have this one
but i'm a bit unsure because of Bishop
e3 of it I think I still should do it it
limits his night
hmm ok c5 got Bishop f5 it's not a big
issue hmm imagine and I'll see that he
has only 95 I wanted to play castles but
no g5 is annoying very annoying actually
and I should play cougar
I should probably really play Bishop e7
that that's the line that I actually
know if it this is also good against
Evans it's not as good as this line
would be if you know it but this is not
so great I mean I don't think I'm in bad
shape objective labored it took me ages
to get him the bishop is really funny on
b6 but it does something supporting that
night I'm catching up a bit on the clock
and just to kick this I completely
forgot that you can take with that move
that's extremely so Jack cannot even
call the detector can just total all the
side I should just play we should be
seven or Lord Bishop b5 chatting for
good its own this is not not good yeah
the Evans gambit is not a good opening
you should not have any problems and
this is just a pretty bad bad result him
so how to do it come on can get some
sort of counter play look on the second
Queen f4 Queen g3 or something time
morning taking see form which is easily
covered
cannot to take say for every one rupee
three okay check I don't know if that
was such a great idea check don't I have
something here t2 doesn't work
unfortunately rook be too nice consisted
check check Queenie 423 those kind of
stuff this kind of stuff and he might
under promote
and the promotion just wins right f8
Queen AF 89 check every night winds
check check Ruby zone check check okay
[Music]
check check check check check back
ornate I am ok I should just play this
line that I know we should be seven is
also fine and I actually know this a
little bit Bishop a five I checked once
for that video that I did and it is fine
for black but I don't I just don't know
the detail and it costs too much time so
here carry that it's not bad for for
Blackie quite clearly words i take too
much time solving those problems and
it's not easy and it was still in bad
shape here i mean but you're down a
minute and then I blunder stupid stuff i
connect this sub C 5 yeah I just didn't
see that this hangs check night see to
actually not that bad according to the
computer not a move that I'll follow at
all and it's a fork he has to do this
that's a completely weird line but I
should have thought about it at least a
little bit yay another good game reject
and yeah I'm just can't struggling I was
a bit surprised that he we can conserve
so much with G forward chest is not good
check objectively speaking and check no
I'm just chillin I'm just lost
ah ok guys thanks for watching